- Well, we could continue
with that graduation theme,
because frankly, that was a fun one.
And you know, the YouTube,
Facebook livestreams
are going to start shortly as well.
I'm gonna repeat what I just said.
But I will also apologize.
I just had a tooth removed.
I had a cracked tooth last week,
and they had to take it,
they had to take it out.
My mom was just calling,
so I just have to,
well, I'll call her back in a little bit.
But I just had a cracked tooth,
and they took it out,
and then they screwed in
I guess a thing that they're going
to eventually have to put the implant.
So, this entire half of my face is numb,
and so, at least today I have
an excuse to sound funny.
Oh, hey everyone.
Now, I'm on, if you see me looking away,
I'm now on Facebook and YouTube.
So, hi everyone on Facebook and YouTube.
Sal here, for our daily
homeroom livestream,
for those of you who are
wondering what this is.
This is really just something we started
when we started seeing school closures
and social distancing, and we said,
hey, this could be a cool way
for all of us to stay in touch.
And sometimes I have guests,
and sometimes we just do ask me anythings.
Today, the guest is me, so
we'll just do ask me anythings.
I was just telling the Instagram crowd,
who is, you know, a little bit lower here.
If you ever see me not making eye contact,
they're right over here.
Oh, I guess, is that me on Instagram?
I don't know, this is bizarre.
Little bit trippy.
But, I was just telling them that I had
a cracked tooth as of last Friday.
I was eating a peach, and which
is not normally considered
to be a hard tooth shattering thing.
But, it did somehow crack
my bottom left molar,
and so it's been incredibly painful.
But considering all that's
happening in the world,
as I say, it's on the edge of the type
of problems you wanna have,
'cause obviously there's a lot
of folks going through
a lot more right now.
So, I just got kind of a
emergency dental thing in my,
this entire half of my face is numb.
Let me see, my mom just called,
so let me, she keeps calling.
Maybe one of these days I'll just answer
the phone with my mom.
That could be entertaining.
But yes, this entire half of
my face is right now numb,
so I have an excuse today to sound funny.
(laughs) A better excuse
than I normally do.
So, before I start,
I do wanna make my standard announcement.
Remind everyone that Khan
Academy is a not for profit,
that we exist only
because of philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself.
So, if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making a donation.
I wanna give a special shout out
to several corporations
that have stepped up
to support Khan Academy
over the last few weeks.
Bank of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Novartis, and Fastly.
Thank you for that support.
With that, let's get
in to the heart of it,
and you know, I might cut it short,
because all sorts of
weird things are happening
in my mouth right now
and I apologize if I
have to wipe my mouth.
Might not be the most pleasant viewing.
But yes, half of my
mouth is right now numb.
I'm a big habit of consistency,
and habit, so that's why I
want to do this regardless.
So please, ask me anything.
All right, some Twitter.
Greg Ferenstein, oh, I know Greg.
I have so many questions.
Does your beard have a nickname?
Will you read me a
bedtime calculus problem?
Can we be friends?
Well, if this is the same Greg
Ferenstein that I do know,
I think we're already friends.
But maybe this is a
different Greg Ferenstein.
My beard does not have a nickname
that I think would be, you know.
I have some eccentricities,
but they have not quite gotten there yet.
Will you read me a
bedtime calculus problem?
Maybe, I'll think about that.
I'll think about how we
can do the logistics.
I'll wait for my tooth to heal
before I think about
bedtime calculus problems.
Okay, from Facebook, and you know,
I said this is a ask me anything.
And it can be literally about anything,
but I thought last week when
we did the graduation theme,
that was also fun, 'cause then
I got to be kinda Uncle Sal
and give life advice and wisdom,
and you could take it for
what it, for what it's worth.
So, from Facebook, Lori-Ann Stalshnere.
I would love to see
school districts convert
to using Khan Academy regularly.
I think the classroom flip,
students watch videos from teachers
or Khan Academy at night
and work through their
assignments in the classroom
will aid teachers.
Why is this approach not implemented yet?
So, those of you who don't
know what Lori's referring to
is something that we've been
sometimes associated with,
but it's not something
that we came up with.
This notion of a flipped
classroom predates Khan Academy.
Arguably this is what,
you know, Socrates did,
where the students would
do reading ahead of time
and then when they got to class,
they would engage in, I guess,
a Socratic dialogue with Socrates.
But the idea is is that the learning,
the information retrieval or coverage
happens at your own time and pace,
and that's especially doable now
in the time of on-demand video.
And that way, when you get to a classroom,
you're able to dive deeper,
do problem solvings, have conversations,
actually have human-to-human interaction.
And so, that's why people call it a flip
and once you do that, you
can actually go even further
because one of the reasons why a classroom
all has to move at the same pace
is because in a traditional
classroom, you have a lecturer,
and a lecturer by definition
is at a fixed pace.
But all of a sudden, if students
are able to watch content
or even practice at their own
time and pace on their own,
then when they get to class,
they can get more supports,
and in theory, every student
could go at a different pace.
And you know, I don't
think it has to be strict
videos at home or lectures at home
and then problem solving in the classroom.
I actually think it could be
whether you're in the
classroom or at home,
you should do whatever
makes sense for you.
So, work at your own time and
pace on exercises and videos,
and then when you're in the classroom,
you have extra supports of
your peers, your teacher,
the teacher could look
at the data and see,
hey, so and so's having a problem
or maybe three students
are having trouble.
I could have a small
group session with them
while the other students continue
to work at their own time and pace.
And we've seen this in
many, many classrooms
and students love it 'cause
it's much more interactive,
they get much more support.
And teachers really like
it 'cause they get to form
these deeper connections and are really
able to do differentiated instruction.
To your question of why
we're not seeing more of it,
I think it's just a, it's a different way
of thinking about classrooms and you know,
for the most part, it
just sometimes takes time
for people to realize there's a shift.
You know, I've given talks
to groups of educators
and they all intellectually
really agree with this idea.
But it is sometimes harder to move past
maybe what you're used
to in traditional model.
The one, you know, one
silver lining perhaps
of this COVID crisis is that we are seeing
many, many more teachers
move to this type of a model
because obviously, with
people staying at home now,
you're not getting as
much, I guess you could say
seat time in the classroom.
And so, a lot more of
the information delivery
or the lectures or
whatever you wanna call it,
and the problem solving has to happen
at the student's own time and pace
and that way when students and teachers
get on Zoom or Google Hangout or whatever,
they have a lot more interaction.
'Cause obviously it makes no sense
to just give a lecture on Zoom.
That might as well just be a video.
And honestly, that's not just about Zoom,
that could be true of the real world too.
If you just, you know,
at some universities,
there'll be a lecture with 300 students,
that could and should be a video.
And ideally, the students and the teachers
could interact with each other instead,
which would be far more human.
And if you see me keep shifting my eyes
from a little part of
my screen to another,
it's because I'm trying
to make eye contact
with both Instagram and the
Facebook, YouTube livestreams
and read the questions, so, my apologies.
All right.
There is, let's see, from
Facebook, Ursa Khan says,
I hope you don't mind,
but I tell people that you're my cousin.
Sounds fine to me, for all
we all, we are cousins,
cousin Ursa.
All right.
There are, YouTube, @ForEasin asks,
if you taught at a public
school, what would you teach?
You know, one of the things that I,
when I was in college, I used to say,
if there was such thing
as a PhD in everything,
that's what I would wanna do.
'Cause I actually can get very excited
about teaching almost anything,
or learning about almost anything.
So, you know, math is interesting,
physics, chemistry, biology,
I would've loved to do literature.
I would love a philosophy course.
I think that's what
keeps things interesting
is where you wanna teach things
where you have some
grounding and familiarity,
but it's also fun to be
on that learning journey
oftentimes with the students.
And oftentimes that makes the teaching
that much more authentic 'cause
you're that much closer to empathizing
with the experience that the students
are having at that moment.
But you know, in in-person classrooms,
I really like as much
interactivity as possible.
You know, we started a little lab school,
it's in our office, it's
called Khan Lab School,
and you know, roughly once
a week or once a month,
I do a seminar with the middle
and upper school students.
And that, we just kinda, you know,
I start with a question.
I just say, what is the
meaning of life, you know?
A small question.
And then really facilitate
a Socratic dialogue,
so I like doing things like that.
Or I like doing simulations
and games with students.
And I like it when you get in the room,
the more cross-disciplinary it could be,
so oftentimes in that hour,
we will go into philosophy,
politics, economics,
physics, math, and I think that's
what really forms the
connections for students.
And frankly, I learn something
interesting every time I do
I think that some of the fun
is when it's not predictable,
when you know, it's not just
from the teacher to the student,
but it's also from the
students to each other
and to the teacher as well.
Let's see.
From Facebook, Ganesh Golipeli.
Do you have any plans to
translate content in English
and Indian languages?
Simple answer is yes,
we have a whole effort going on in India.
And we have a team in
Delhi and in Bangalore
that is redoing and translating content
into the largest Indian languages.
We also have a project in Hinglish,
for those of you who are not familiar,
that is a hybrid of Hindi and English,
which is apparently a fairly standard
method of learning a lot of topics
or the language of education
in a lot of north India.
So yeah, we are doing that, simple answer.
So, look that up, look up,
you know, Khan Academy India,
and I think you should
be able to find that.
Okay, from Facebook, Kasava Riman asks,
how long did you study?
And how long do you recommend study?
How are you motivated to
study when you were young?
So, I guess that question, you know,
do you mean how many
years did I go to school?
Or when I studied in school,
how long did I study?
I guess I'll answer both.
In terms, I guess the first
one's easier to answer.
You know, my undergrad,
I did a master's degree,
but all of that stuff
happened in about four years.
And that was in CS and math
and a master's in computer
science, electrical engineering,
and then I went to business
school for two years.
So you can add up.
And then I was working
for two and a half years
between undergraduate and business school.
So that's how long I went to school,
formal schooling, I guess you could say.
In terms of how long did I study,
it really depended on the context.
And depending on what I
was doing at the time.
What I found in courses
like math and physics
and chemistry and biology,
essentially STEM courses,
or even, you know, programming courses,
I found that if you do the problem sets,
and you're always just thinking about it,
then you actually don't
need to do a lot of studying
or a lot of cramming.
If, you know, the professor
is about to do a problem,
try to do it ahead of time or
try to do it at the same time
that the professor's doing it.
If you're doing all the problem sets,
you're doing all the projects,
I found that the tests are
actually quite intuitive.
You know, I have peers,
and I don't think it's
anything about intelligence,
who sometimes would, you know,
they're kind of mindlessly
note-taking in a class,
and maybe not actively learning.
And then they find that when they go
right before the final exam,
they have to do a lot of cramming.
And so, I'm a much bigger
fan of active learning.
You know, in one old school house,
I was a little bit
infamous in college that,
you know, certain lectures
I found a lot of value in
and I found that I could
do that active learning
and I could, and then others, I did not.
And so, I sometimes didn't go to them,
and instead, I would go and I
would get get out the textbook
and I would do problems on my own.
And I found if I did that all term,
then when I got to the class,
then I would, you know,
when I got the exam,
I had to do a lot less real studying.
But other subjects that might've had,
you know, more content to them,
or more terminology, you know,
I wish I could say that
I wasn't, you know,
a super procrastinator, but
there were times in college
that I pulled at
all-nighters and you know,
and in hindsight, I wish that
I had done it more regularly,
you know, the more
mature kind of, you know,
fully developed frontal
lobe Sal would've said,
yeah, you know, if I just worked on it
a couple hours every day,
then I would've not had to
pull those all-nighters,
but you know, in college,
you might find yourself,
you know, three, four, five, six hours
the night before a test
if you haven't been
doing what you're
supposed to up until then,
you might have to do that type of thing.
But I don't condone it.
But yeah, you know, you're going to have
to be the judge yourself
of how much to study.
But I think the most important
thing in everything in life,
you know, I say this about Khan Academy,
it's okay to binge do
it every now and then,
but the better is to form a regular habit,
20, 30, 40 minutes a day in anything
is going to actually build those muscles.
And frankly, not only will you not
have to cram for the test,
but you're likely to
have better retention.
'Cause oftentimes you
just cram for the test,
you take the test, you
go sleep for 16 hours,
and you wake up, you're
like, what just happened?
(laughs) You might not remember
a lot of what just happened.
All right, so there's, from
Facebook, oh, this is Duo,
this is Khan Academy Duo.
Tell us why you love some
of your favorite science
fiction authors, please.
And then Dan from Khan Academy is asking,
"Dune" or "Foundation," which
one do you prefer and why?
So, to answer Duo, you know, some of my,
well, the second question
from Dan kinda answers.
You know, I'm a big Arthur C. Clarke fan.
Obviously, kind of the
whole "2001" series,
the whole notion of, I also
like "Childhood's End."
There's a bunch of good
Arthur C. Clarke stuff
that are very enjoyable.
Isaac Asimov I've talked a lot about.
And George Herbert, "Dune," I mean,
you can see behind me a lot
of these books are there.
Let's see, can I, where's the "Dune?"
But you know, I'm not a big believer
in stack ranking everything in your life.
You know, it's like stack
ranking your children, you know?
You love them all and they all
add dimensions to your life.
But I'll tell you why I
loved many of these things.
You know, "Foundation," I've
talked about it many times,
the "Foundation" series, I'm
not giving the plot away,
it's a good read.
And I envy any of y'all
who haven't read it
because you get to enjoy
it for the first time.
But it takes place 30,000
years in the future,
humanity has colonized the galaxy.
And there's kind of this
mathematician, historian,
you know, psychologist-type
academic named Hari Seldon
who develops this
science of psychohistory.
And he, through his math, shows that
there's a very high probability
that the galactic empire
is about to enter into
a 10,000 year dark ages.
And he decides to do something about it.
His math shows him, his science shows him
that if he's able to collect the galaxy's,
the civilization's knowledge,
and put it in the periphery
of the galaxy as a foundation,
that will shorten the dark ages
from 10,000 years to 1,000 years.
And you know, when I read that as a kid,
I think I first read it in middle school,
I was like, this is epic.
Well, you know, first of all,
it was the first time I'd
really appreciated that,
you know what?
Hari Seldon is right.
The single most important
nugget for civilization
or for people is at the end of the day
how much they're able to
leverage their human potential,
and that all boils down
to, really, knowledge.
And so, that's number one,
and that probably put a
seed in my mind later on
when I was working on
Khan Academy that like,
this could matter a lot.
Maybe Khan Academy could be
this foundation for the world
that could maybe prevent us
from getting into a dark age
or maybe elevate humanity
to a whole other level,
whatever else.
And the other thing that I
was inspired by by Hari Seldon
was that he thought on that timeframe.
You know, most of us do not think,
oh, what's going to happen
in a thousand years?
What can I help to keep, you know,
that 10,000 years of
pain and war and famine
instead being 1,000
years, 'cause you know,
a lot of us said, well, you know,
I've probably got another, I don't know,
60 years on this planet at best.
I mean, many of you young people watching
hopefully will have many, many more years.
And you know, we can talk about, you know,
this whole notion of the singularity
and if medical science can
extend lifespans, who knows?
There might be some generation
that lives much, much longer.
Actually, I think we're
gonna bring David Sinclair,
who's done research on that,
onto our livestream at some point.
But you know, I was inspired that by,
well, maybe we should be
thinking on type of a timeframe
because that's probably
what's gonna help humanity.
And it doesn't even
have to be 10,000 years
or a thousand years, but you can think
on a hundred-year timeframe
or a 50-year timeframe,
which I found incredibly inspiring.
And that I've told many of y'all
that was one of the reasons why
I set up Khan Academy as a not for profit.
It was illusional 10 years ago
when I was operating in this
very same walk-in closet
that I'm in right now.
And but I said, you know,
maybe Khan Academy could be
like the Foundation, it could serve,
one day, billions of kids
for hundreds of years.
And be one of the great
institutions of the world.
And it was frankly outright
delusional back then,
but it's feeling a lot
less delusional now.
You know, we have a hundred
million registered users,
there's no reason can't get,
we've grown a hundredfold
over the last 10 years.
Why couldn't we grow another
tenfold and get to a billion?
And really build out the
content and the software
and the tools and all of
the stuff so that we really,
you know, that, no matter
where you are born,
if you at least have access
to a low cost device,
and the devices are
getting cheaper every day,
and internet access,
then you have a lifeline.
It could be in some village
that, you know, has no school.
You still have a lifeline.
Or it could be a place
that does have a school
and then you're able to use this thing
to empower the school,
to empower the teachers,
so that you get more personalization
and more access to more content.
And you know, there's ideas of, you know,
ways to pair people that one student
could tutor another student,
even if they're in
completely different places
or different countries.
So, anyway, that's "Foundation."
"Dune" is really, you know,
"Dune" is epic because
it also takes place,
I think, several thousand
years in the future.
And you know, it's obviously,
it's kind of an allegory for the whole,
you know, energy, and whether, you know,
many would argue that, you know,
because of oil in the Middle East,
that has made the Middle
East a very tough,
you know, especially
coming out of World War I,
when people realized that
oil was very valuable
and the Ottoman Empire was broken up.
You know, that's why
you had that instability
because there'd been so
much interest in oil,
which is, you know, obviously
it can be an issue of national security
and definitely an issue
of economic security.
And so, "Dune" takes place, I think,
3,000 years in the future,
but it's the same thing,
that there's this planet,
Arrakis, that you can mine spice,
and spice is used by the navigators
to be able to do interstellar travel.
And so it's analogous to oil,
but that makes Arrakis, which has a lot
of parallels to the Middle East,
it's kind of a desert planet,
and it has some of these, you know,
there's some nomadic
people who live there.
But it makes them kind of a tension point,
and so there's kind of a power grab there.
So, it's a good metaphor for
geopolitics and politics,
but then there's also a bit
of a metaphysical layer on it
where the main character
is kind of perceived
as the kind of the savior
on a religious level,
you know, there's this concept in Islam
known as the Mahdi, which
is kind of the savior,
the person who comes, you
know, at some future point.
And so, the people who live on Arrakis
are kind of this neo-Islamic, you know,
you can imagine how religions might evolve
over thousands of years, and
so, they still have retained
and they think the main character is that,
and he does seem to have certain powers
or data points to back that up.
So anyway, as you can imagine,
anything that is truly
epic and expands your mind,
and makes you kind of think beyond the,
oh, I have to go to a dentist
appointment to remove my tooth
or you know, I better go buy
some baking soda tonight,
and instead makes you think about, like,
wow, what are we?
And where are in the whole
scope of time and space?
And what could we become
as a civilization?
I think is always really interesting.
But you know, I think we sometimes forget
that we are an intermediary
on some form of pathway,
of some form of, you know,
humanity a thousand years from now
might be very, very different
than humanity today.
But we, you know, us, the collective we,
are the people who are going to kind of
define what that trajectory is,
so it's just really interesting
things to think about.
So, let's see.
Virvinder Bojwani asks,
what are the top
challenges for Khan Academy
to scale their product
from just add-on education
to become an official
part of school curriculum.
Specifically in developing countries
like Pakistan and India, where
government school systems
can benefit a lot from Khan Academy.
Well, there's a lot of things,
you know, at the beginning of this,
I made my standard plug for resources.
You know, we are the budget
of a large high school.
It is a substantial budget,
but we're the budget
of a large high school,
but we reach over a hundred
million students in a year,
so, you know, I'd like
to make the argument
it's a very strong social
return on investment
and that could one day be billions.
We need to add more content, you know,
we're starting to add
English and language arts,
I would love to add middle school science.
We already have, really, math from pre-K
with Khan Academy Kids all the way
through high school and
early college-level math.
The sciences, biology,
chemistry, and physics
are either added or being
improved upon as we speak.
And then, and so, I think that
lays a very strong scaffold,
we wanna constantly improve the software,
the exercises on Khan Academy,
so you get as much practice
and feedback as you need.
We're constantly looking at the data
so that we can improve those items.
You know, I'm intrigued
by things in the future.
How can you use Khan Academy as evidence
for what you know to the broader world?
So it can plug you into higher education
or you can even get a job
or whatever else from Khan Academy.
And then I think there
is a very real issue
of device access and training and support.
And we are starting to
do that type of work.
We're working with school
districts, we're mainly in the US,
but we do have efforts
in places like India
and Brazil as well to start integrating
with their technology and
their rostering systems
and do training with their teachers
and their administrators.
And then, you know, you
can imagine device access,
especially in places
like India or Pakistan,
are not where they need to be
in order to fully leverage Khan Academy
to empower teachers and
students and schools.
But you know, my hope is,
over the next 10 years,
a lot of that stuff is going to happen.
And frankly, the COVID crisis
is accelerating a lot of that.
So, let's see.
There, from Instagram, Wdic07 says,
do you play an instrument?
I do kind of, I play guitar.
I'm, you know, I'm a mediocre guitarist.
I usually, it's more of a
means to an end, to sing.
And I'm mediocre at that as well.
I've picked up a little bit of piano,
my oldest son is actually
quite good at piano,
and I've kind of observed
what he's been up to.
And so, but even there, you know,
my piano is really just an excuse
to belt out a tune every now and then.
So let's see, we have,
oh, we only have a little bit more time.
So let's see, are there
any other questions?
So, a couple of people are asking
about the Junior Breakthrough Challenge.
KatieAU and Natalie O.
Advice for the Breakthrough
Junior Challenge,
excited about the Junior
Breakthrough Challenge,
first of all, I am excited about it.
For those of you do not know what it is,
now the Junior Breakthrough
Challenge is a,
there's the breakthrough prizes,
which you can kind of view
as the new Nobel Prizes
where several folks out
here in Silicon Valley,
led by Yuri Milner, but
also Mark Zuckerberg
and Sergei Brin and Eric Schmidt.
They funded this prize,
it's like a Nobel Prize,
so you know, these top
mathematicians and scientists
and doctors in the world,
they give a three million dollar prize
for like really, you know,
disruptions or you know,
breakthrough type of discoveries.
And they reached out to Khan Academy
about five, six years ago, and said,
well, we wanna do something
for high school students.
And what we came up with is
what if high school students
created short videos
that explained a phenomenon in math,
medicine, or science in just a novel way.
And if you win the Breakthrough
Prize, it is a lot.
You get, I think it's
a $250,000 scholarship,
your teacher gets $50,000,
there's a hundred thousand
dollar lab for your school,
so it's like approaching
half a million dollars
for a three-minute video,
so it's a good ROI, I think.
And I am one of the judges.
And you know, the ones that
I've always found appealing are,
it's always great to
have a sense of humor,
I would say almost every
winner, not every winner,
but especially some of the, you know,
if you can make someone chuckle
while they're getting their mind blown,
you're doing great.
(laughs) That's--
So, humor's great.
But I think the really
good ones are just like,
even for someone who's an expert
or thought they know about that field,
they're like, oh, I never thought
about it exactly that way.
And I think if you can give
that aha, and you know,
many of the judges beyond me
are some of these Nobel Prize winners,
Breakthrough Challenge
winners, things like that.
So if you can make even
a Nobel Prize winner say,
hmm, I'm obviously an
expert on that topic,
but I never thought about
it exactly in that way,
and by the way, that was kind of funny,
I think you have a good
chance of winning. (laughs)
And that's, and I would say,
it's not just about the prize.
Just the activity of doing it,
I think, is really, really powerful.
And I think creating
portfolios of things like this,
regardless of whether you
win or you're a finalist,
you show it to colleges,
you show it to employers,
you show it to people
you're interested in dating,
and I think they'll be impressed.
So let's see, maybe one question.
Okay, I'll take this one from Instagram.
OpiumYum says, how can I become smarter?
I just feel like no matter how hard I try,
I can't learn anything.
Well, OpiumYum, hopefully your username
doesn't correlate too much
with things going on your life,
'cause that might be
part of the explanation.
No, but in all seriousness,
I think you just have to have
a growth mindset about it.
You know, this notion that
somehow intelligence is fixed
is a flawed way of thinking about it
and in some ways becomes
a self-fulling prophecy.
So, I think the best way
to, quote, "get smarter,"
is to engage on things
that you can engage on
but are challenging to you
and are a little bit frustrating to you,
but when you do it, what you find is
if you keep you keep engaging on it
for 20, 30 minutes a
day, 40 minutes a day,
you're gonna notice in
two, three, four months
that all of a sudden, that thing that
you thought was difficult,
you're able to do quite well.
It's just like anything,
it's like going to the gym or running.
If you run every day for 20 minutes,
you're gonna shave
minutes off of your mile
before you know it.
And so, I would recommend Khan Academy
as a great place to do it.
It's all free, it's all non-commercial.
Start at the beginning of math
if you wanna start in math.
And do one plus one equals two,
you can use the course challenges
and the unit tests to
accelerate you through it.
And if, OpiumYum, you do 20,
30 minutes of that a day,
come back in six months and tell me
if you do not genuinely
feel a lot smarter.
Because I think in about six months,
you will have gotten to your grade level,
you will have gotten
beyond your grade level.
If you are an adult, you would have found
that all of those things
that you found intimidating
when you were in, you know,
algebra class or whatever,
you're like, wait, that's not so bad
now that I have a good foundation,
now that I'm really building
a habit of learning it.
So, I think it's all about
having growth mindset,
and realizing that you learn the most
when you step out of your comfort zone.
You don't really know
how intelligent you are
until you push yourself.
Failing, you know, I like
the term fail forward.
Failing is actually an
opportunity for growth,
it's actually your best
opportunity for growth.
And you keep up with it, and
really, the sky's the limit.
So, I'm gonna stop there.
This is a lot of fun.
I could keep going, but you know,
thank you for joining this livestream.
And I will see everyone on Monday.
So, I'm--